robert robert toi le maire de béziers tu
nous a bien
[Musique]
prouvé
que dans la vie il faut toujours croire
en ses rêves tu t'es dévoués en
reprenant ce poste car franchement à
part des emmerdes qui d'autre aurait
repris cette ville de
[Musique]
75000 habitants
des réformes choc et des décisions
fermes bientôt tu ira plus loin que
l'hérault et un jour toi aussi tu sera
connu dans l'univers comme le célèbre
adolphe sax l'inventeur du saxophone
mais non mais non non robert attends
attends faire [ __ ]
robert bret
se termine arrête toi ils saluent
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
1h10 tube abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux